[Music]
we all collectively screamed when
descendants unexpectedly dropped their
under-the-sea trailer but have you
managed to catch all hidden clues about
this short 10-minute story don't forget
to hit that notification valve to never
miss another video and be sure to check
out our community section for even more
fun now let's check out these descendant
clues dizzy why are you wearing Oma's
necklace dizzy is evil okay let's get
this one out of the way so Dizzy's gone
to the bad side has she this just brings
us so many new potential plot stories
and twists she was supposed to go to art
on prep remember and what is she doing
anywhere near uma in the first place or
maybe it isn't dizzy to begin with we
have a feelings to play a much more
important part in the third movie and
we're so totally here for it but make
sure to keep on watching because
descendants totally pulled an awesome
switcheroo for this one
Dizzy's also totally grown up since the
second movie remember she was just a
little kid then based on the trailer it
looks like she's going head to head with
now right mom earth did Emma tell Disney
to make her go again soon now to begin
with and speaking of mouth why is she
wearing her old wig when her hair should
be way less pink we have so many
questions but it looks like we'll get
the answers faster than expected the
shorts coming to Disney in fall 2018
that's not such a long wait is it it'll
definitely keep us occupied until we get
the actual movie next year but does this
mean dizzy will be on Emma side in the
movie too well it's a bit more
complicated than that no wait that's
actually uma many fans are speculating
that the character we saw isn't actually
dizzy it's uma who changed form to trick
now it looks like these two still
haven't buried the hatchet with
whatever's going on one YouTube user
pointed out that this is supposedly
taking place right after the second
movie after the battle between Malin uma
and we've all seen uma at the end of the
second movie telling the audience that
this isn't over yet so maybe she has a
revenge in mind revenge so strong she
can't wait for the third movie and had
to release it all in this short first
the one big clue that dizzy is actually
uma is the fact that she's wearing her
necklace unless these two have made a
deal together and win against mal
there's no way
uma would get dizzy her
Klis it's just not possible but if it's
Ouma who transforms into dizzy that just
gives us a whole new storyline to work
with considering dizzy reacted like
she's in pain when the necklace
activated there's just no way this
wouldn't be luma and dizzy swarm dizzy
would have never had such a strong
connection to the necklace since it can
only be activated by people connected to
the see which new super powers
it looks like umas necklace will play an
important part in this short in the
second movie Ouma was searching for the
missing pieces of the necklace she
needed them to seek out the Trident we
all know the movie ends with Ouma
seeking revenge for not getting the
Trident so maybe that's exactly what's
happening here and by the looks of it
she's really going to play with mouths
emotions won't she but another important
thing to remember is that Emma's
necklace which belongs to her mother
holds superpowers remember it has the
ability to enable shape-shifting and
store other people's voices so it would
make total sense that Ouma would
transform into dizzy the question is how
on earth did she manage to catch dizzy
if she's at auradon prep or did the
necklace actually become more powerful
over time and Ouma was just able to
transform him into dizzy without having
her around the short better be long
enough to answer all these questions for
us but we're very excited to see the
necklace being used again we briefly saw
it when Emma posed as her mother but now
it looks like the necklace will be used
in the same way as it was in the Little
Mermaid loving these connections I came
across this
the spin-off this is a spin-off that
will appear before the official movie
comes out in 2019 it's very rare that
this happens in movies in the first
place but by the looks of it the
descendants team wanted to put this out
to answer some unanswered questions or
so we think because many have pointed
out that the first trailer which was
meant for the third movie now doesn't
make sense did you catch it
in the first trailer mal finds her
father's blue orb but she also talks
about the orb to dizzy when she comes
out of the woods it does indeed look
like mouths being guided by uma but the
order of these trailers just doesn't
make sense because now we still don't
have any information on what will
potentially happen in the third movie it
looks like all of this was meant for the
short or maybe this was just another way
for the descendants to keep us from
speculating about what will happen in
the third movie well either way since we
got two trailers for the spin-off
descendants owes us at least one trailer
for the actual movie rights other actors
so we now know that dizzy and now we'll
both appear in this short but who else
can we expect well considering this is
all sea themed and the fact that emma is
also there you know she'll need her
pirate crew back up according to
headline planet.com
our faves are returning even if it's
just for a short 10 minutes well make
that extra 10 minutes because we also
knows they'll be there in the third
movie it's a win-win so who's going to
be back and looks like Dylan Playfair
and Thomas Doherty will be making an
appearance in the under the Seas short
that means the entire pirate crew will
be back together a question is if this
is all based under the sea does it mean
all these characters can now breathe
underwater
we have a feeling there will definitely
be some new super powers involved or who
knows maybe we'll even get to see a
secret underwater city you never know
what will happen with the Simmins a
while back we have no idea they'll even
make a short 10-minute story the one
thing that we do know is we're
definitely ready for it what do you
think will happen in this short come let
us know in the comments we'd love to
hear your thoughts and that's it for our
video thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]